until recently ilya shapiro was a
lecturer at georgetown law and one of
the most prominent then he criticized
joe biden's decision to nominate a
supreme court justice on the basis of
race
because race is irrelevant to judicial
temperament knowledge experience wisdom
etc
for saying that georgetown law put
shapiro on leave they announced a
months-long investigation now the probe
ultimately cleared shapiro on a
technicality but he says he's leaving
the school anyway we are honored to have
elio shapiro formerly of georgetown law
he's the author of supreme disorder
judicial nominations the politics of
america's highest court is shapiro joins
us thank you very much for coming out a
lot of people followed this
outside the legal world outside
the world of georgetown um are we
leaving anything out was your crime just
pointing out that race is irrelevant to
whether a judge is good or not
look i had a tweet that i didn't phrase
as well as i would have liked i'm sure
all of us are guilty of that
at one time or another my underlying
point is exactly as you stated and i
think it was unreasonable or with bad
faith to read it as being misogynistic
or racist it's ironic that i'm being
criticized that i was criticized that i
was put under investigation for
criticizing joe biden for applying a
racial and gender-based test for his
supreme court nominees but here we are
and
four months later i was cleared on a
technicality last week it took them four
months the investigators at the
diversity office and and otherwise to
see that i was not an employee when i
tweeted and they cleared me on that but
insinuated that i or anybody else who
said or wrote anything that would offend
anyone
would be creating a hostile educational
establishment and i could not work under
that
arrangement and so i had to resign
yesterday well you made the honorable
decision and i admire that working at
georgetown law is considered a big deal
i think what's scary about the story is
this didn't happen at nike
right or the nfl or something this
happened at georgetown law where there
are a lot of serious people i know a lot
of people who work there
weren't they embarrassed to be
investigating you for expressing an
entirely mainstream and defensible
position on twitter
i mean i'm not going to speak for anyone
else
but i think if you know nationwide and
as georgetown specifically there are a
lot of cowardly administrators who uh
refuse to stand up to the activist
radical woke mob uh who insists that
there is no deviation from a progressive
orthodoxy i mean contrary to the
diversity equity inclusion offices that
have proliferated throughout the land
they're encouraging they're discouraging
intellectual diversity preventing equal
opportunity and excluding any voices
that would dissent from the prevailing
view so i've been i've been really
disappointed i'm sad that this has all
happened i don't think i was naive but i
mean it's it's really really bad if um i
don't think any uh faculty members uh
staff member student at such an
institution can really thrive uh because
there's a sort of damocles and that's
why i that's why i left i could not uh
stay at a place where if i'm commenting
on a supreme court opinion or teaching a
class and someone says they're
uncomfortable or claims they're offended
and all of a sudden i'm back in the
storm chamber
yeah i mean that's that's the end of a
great american institution after
hundreds of years and it's uh it's it's
bigger even in your particular case it
says something really ominous i think
and i appreciate you be willing to talk
about it and the principle stand that
you have to let you know tucker my next
move i'm now going to be the director of
constitutional studies at the manhattan
institute which is a wonderful
organization based in new york i'm going
to stay in the dc area northern virginia
where i live and
they do a lot of they make a lot of
great counterintuitive points on policy
and i'm delighted to expand their
constitutional program amen work with a
lot of people who have been friends for
a long time
we'll see you again haley shapiro thank
you so much thank you